good afternoon i'm officer miss el para
that's m-i-s-a-e-l-p-a-r-r-a
i'm a public information officer with
las vegas metropolitan police department
this afternoon shortly after 4 p.m lbmpd
received a 9-1-1 call from a person
reporting that there had been a shooting
at a convenience store in the 1100 block
of south las vegas boulevard officers
responded and located three victims who
were suffering from gunshot wounds
all three of those victims have been
transported to umc
hospital with injuries
officers that were in the area located a
suspect vehicle a red dodge
neon who matched the description they
attempted to stop that vehicle however
that vehicle
took off and officers pursued the
vehicle
our air unit was also overhead and they
followed the vehicle to the area of
desert end
and swenson where that vehicle collided
with two citizen vehicles
the four occupants in the suspect
vehicle then
fled the area one of the suspects who
was fleeing
in the roadway was struck by another
vehicle
and that suspect has been transported to
umc trauma
the remaining three suspects were taken
into custody
one of those suspects has been
transported to
you i'm sorry to sunrise hospital
for minor injuries and the other two are
in custody
at this time this is an ongoing
investigation anybody who may have been
in the area at the time of the shooting
who may have been a witness
is urged to call 3-1-1 or to remain
anonymous call
fifty five that's a 385-5555 stoppers
line so just to clarify the three
individuals who were shot or shot inside
a
convenience store what we believe at
this time is that there was some sort of
uh altercation that took place inside
the convenience store
which spilled to the outside and at that
point one of the suspects produced a
firearm
and began began to shoot at at least one
of the subjects involved in the
altercation
but the obligation took place outside of
the community
as the suspect was fleeing from officers
he struck
two citizen vehicles uh in that area of
desert inn
and switzerland and what's the condition
of the occupants of those other vehicles
neither of those uh involved citizens
were
transported to the hospital we were
hearing from employees earlier that the
gunfire came
out of the car were they all outside of
the vehicle or were they
driving away at this point it's too
early to
to know uh officers are still trying to
determine that
so yeah i couldn't answer that question
right now
it's too early in the investigation
that all came out of that one correct
and they are all
in custody this time we don't believe
there's anybody outstanding
victims
yes three victims two sustained gunshot
wounds have all been transferred to unc
trump
we were called one in critical thinking
that's the information i have one of
them is in critical condition at this
time
just possibly
um how long do you plan on having this
area blocked off and same for the others
i would imagine for at least the next uh
hour or two
obviously we'll be out here processing
the crime scene
so citizens should expect the closure to
last for about another hour or two
not at this time alright guys thanks so
much